we know that this is not going to pass
why
oh so close Emily it looks like they
could very likely supporters of this
project get 59 votes in favor of
approving the Keystone XL pipeline
effectively bypassing the president and
making this thing a reality they needed
60 votes the magic number of 60 we don't
have the final tally yet so we don't
know exactly how far they fell short but
every indication is they could hit as
close as 59 so a defeat here for Mary
Landrieu the Democratic senator from
Louisiana who forced this vote
effectively after the election she's
still trying to hold on to her Senate
seat in Louisiana and one of the
thoughts here was that by bringing this
to the floor by showing her independence
from the president and and showing her
support for the energy industry in her
home state and bringing this bill to the
floor just maybe it could help her in
that runoff election against bill
Cassidy in Louisiana but her efforts and
significant efforts on the floor today
looks like they're gonna fall short and
that she's not going to be able to do
that and this project which has been on
the drawing board now for six years
remains in a sort of limbo here in
Washington with the president saying
he's going to wait for the environmental
review that's happening at the State
Department for litigation in the state
of Nebraska to run its course before he
makes the ultimate decision along with
Secretary of State John Kerry whether or
not this project is indeed in the
nation's interest it could still move
forward but at this point it's still in
limbo Peter does Democrat Landro still
distance herself enough from Democrat
President Obama just by getting this to
a vote I think that was the the approach
all along it was going to be a heavy
lift and there was even the possibility
of course that had this been successful
that the president would have each of
this legislation than she would have
been back to square one but the goal
here for Mary Landrieu politically was
to make this fuss if you will to make
this case on the floor show her
independence and the indications we get
court from talking to folks in Louisiana
is that certainly it hasn't hurt Mary
Landrieu in a runoff election but this
is not going to be enough I've heard a
lot of analysts say to push her over the
top she's trailing in that race against
Bill Cassidy and again this may help as
she's pulled out some squeakers in the
past but maybe not enough to
do it in this race December 6 is that
election and voting is officially over
it has been officially defeated 59 yeses
one short of the 60 that they needed for
this to pass Cory talk to us a little
bit about why this pipeline is so
important for Louisiana's economy in
Louisiana business well I mean Louisiana
has some of the most in the Gulf have
some of the most important US oil
deposits in gas for that matter but
really oil and it's a state whose future
has been decided a lot by the success
and the revenues they've derived from
the oil business there was a ton of oil
fields a lot of shallow Gulf waters just
off the coast of Louisiana the Eugene
Island fields in particular has some
really strong both shallow and deep
water wells that are how people make
their money in Louisiana so the
political strength of the oil business
Louisiana
it can't be overestimated it's a big
deal politically there because people
believe Norrell business in in New
Orleans in Baton Rouge and throughout
the state on that note however Peter
didn't this vote come down to more than
more concern about the scene who was
going to get that seep and whether the
pipeline would actually exist well I
think certainly this pipeline and the
energy industry is a big issue a big
stakeholder in the state of Louisiana
and both bill Cassidy and and Mary
Landrieu were in favor of this this
project but this is a this had more to
do the opposition to it had more to do
with this pipeline whether it was on in
the nation's interest we heard a lot of
arguments on the floor today that this
pipeline would only provide 35 permanent
jobs far fewer than the 40,000 or so
that have been advertised through the
course of the conversation by supporters
most of those jobs temporary
construction jobs and the other argument
you heard from Barbara Boxer of
California and other opponents is that
this oil would effectively come from the
oil sands of Canada Western Canada down
through the United States of the
Louisiana Gulf Coast to the Texas
refined beaver fine there and then move
elsewhere other parts of the world this
was not oil by and large that was going
to remain in the United States they made
the case as a result of that it was not
in the nation's interest again the
majority voted in favor of this project
moving on with it but those opponents
held their ground too certainly to the
with the support of environmental groups
here in Washington
and a lot of this that were the lack of
efficacy of the oil sands to produce the
oil in a clean way to get it out of the
ground cleanly so much fossil fuels had
to be burned just to get that oil up and
then to distribute it and put that into
use Tom Steyer pretty much right across
the street from its former chairman of
Fair Lawn Capital really leading a
nationwide political battle against the
Keystone XL pipeline saying that the
ultimate damage to our society could be
enormous and last for hundreds of years
and that this is the most important
thing to fight as a business to protect
the world from climate change at this
pipeline to encourage the oil sands
could really damage the world
irreparably Peter where do we go from
here well we've got of course the
president could still ultimately approve
it but we expect first of all is that
the republican-controlled Senate in
January will have another vote just like
this and very likely that one will be
successful put the president the same
box that everything decide whether or
not he stands in the way or whether he
waits for the full review process to
play out all right Peter Cook our chief
Washington correspondent on Capitol Hill
that Keystone XL pipeline votes is
seated in the Senate